luego de doce largos años y 139
capítulos el manga de zinc equino que
hoy y finalmente ha terminado dando un
cierre a una de las historias más
intrigantes y emocionantes que japón nos
ha entregado en años recientes y aunque
tuvo un final que dividió a los fans en
dos bandos los que les gustó y los que
no les gustó y le supo a poco a pesar de
eso creo que es admirable todo el
trabajo esfuerzo y dedicación allí me
hizo llama le puso hasta ahora pues te
gustó no todos tenemos que estar de
acuerdo en que pocas historias han sido
tan éticas y emocionantes como lo fue
esta así que hoy quiero dedicarle un
vídeo especial a singh equino que hoy en
dando un vistazo rápido a su capítulo
final y todo el desenlace de la serie
que analizando el general a zinc equino
que oyen como obra y descubrir qué fue
lo que hizo que esta historia resaltará
sobre los demás y fuera tan buena porque
lo fue no me jodas así que toma todo
esto como una enorme y obvia advertencia
de spoiler
[Música]
hay que aclarar antes de comenzar que te
guste o no la dirección final del cine
que no que hoy independientemente de eso
la obra es increíblemente buena y a lo
largo de sus más de 10 años fue una de
las series más épicas que ha habido
gigantes dándose puntadas o soldados
haciendo maromas erwin gritando con
todas las fuerzas de su alma mi casa la
serie es excelente y siempre lo será
pero gyan tanto en el capítulo final la
verdad es que si deja un mal sabor de
boca no por ser un mal final porque la
verdad es que no lo es y mira que he
visto finales malos y finales perversos
y que cree meca bronce lo que es un mal
final pero este capítulo en particular
no es un mal cierre pero no deja de
sentirse como que pudo haber sido mejor
aprovechado pero veamos el porqué el
capítulo 139 a diferencia de la mayoría
de la serie no tiene madrazos ni peleas
épicas el más un capítulo de resolución
y de ver el futuro de cada uno de los
personajes o los que quedan
comenzamos con armen y eren hablando
acerca del por qué eren hizo lo que hizo
y por qué se distanció de todos sus
amigos aquí se nos hacen un par de
revelaciones como que eren al usar el
poder de los titanes en algún momento
pudo ver el pasado y el futuro y en
cierto modo manipular algunos eventos de
la historia e involuntariamente el mismo
fue que envió a su hogar al titán que
devorar y a su madre
además también se nos revela que el plan
de eren era realmente erradicar el poder
de los titanes para que los aldeanos ya
no fueran una amenaza para amarle y
pudieran dejar la guerra atrás eren
quería convertirse en el enemigo de la
humanidad entera y separarse por
completo de sus amigos para que no lo
relacionaran con él pues él sabía que
tarde o temprano sus amigos serían los
que acabarían con él y así podrían dejar
el hoyo atrás y convertirse en los
héroes de la humanidad a medida que
siguen hablando eran por fin confiesa su
amor por mi casa pero en una manera muy
tóxica ya que dice que quiere que sea
feliz pero que no puede aceptar verla
con alguien más y que le gustaría que
solamente viviera sola llorando por él
esta parte sí que no me gustó porque
muestra una faceta de eren completamente
distinta a todo lo que habíamos visto en
la serie es como si fuera alguien
completamente distinto y la verdad un
tanto patético sin mencionar la obvia
relación tóxica entre él y mi casa que
nos deja esta conversación pero en fin
luego de esto eren y armen finalmente se
despiden y se nos dice que armen no fue
el único con el que eren habló pues al
mismo tiempo eren está hablando con
todos y cada uno de sus compañeros
logrando que todos puedan entenderlo y
eso es perdonarlo y agradecerle por lo
que hizo los poderes de los titanes
habían desaparecido de la faz de la
tierra
liv así que vivo x donde se nos muestra
es la mejor escena de todo el capítulo y
observa por última vez a hanjin erwin y
a todos los compañeros caídos para poder
despedirse a ellos con su mano en su
corazón y antes de que todo termine mi
casa sale entre el humo sosteniendo la
cabeza de eren dejando que armen se
despida antes de que ella también se
despida de él y se marche para enterrar
a eren ocurre un salto en el tiempo de
tres años en el futuro en donde vemos el
desenlace de los personajes historia
acude a de su hija que tuvo con granjero
kun a pesar de los deseos de eren el
mundo sigue en guerra
armin y los demás viajan a otros lugares
para tratar de obtener la paz al igual
que en silla de ruedas y finalmente
vemos como mi casa pasa sus días junto a
la tumba de eren llorando por no haber
podido vivir a su lado pero cuando su
bufanda se comienza a caer una vela
recoge y se la pone nuevamente lo que
nos demuestra que de una manera u otra
eren cumplió la promesa que alguna vez
le hizo a mi casa y que le pondría su
bufanda las veces que haga falta
mirando cómo la ves en marcha mi casa le
agradece a eren y se despide de la única
persona que amo terminando así zinc
equino coaching
hoy estoy confundido es un final triste
o un final feliz es un final y más está
como ve en el capítulo final del manga
no es que sea malísimo pero no deja de
sentirse como una oportunidad
desperdiciada el final de singh equipo
que hoy en poder cerrado con broche de
oro lo que de principio a fin fue una
gran historia pero no pues además dejar
muchos cabos sueltos y temas inconclusos
nos deja con un mal sabor de boca que se
siente insatisfactorio de leer por
ejemplo hay muchas cosas que a mí no me
gustaron del final no se nos dice qué
pasó con el gusano gigante de la
historia forzada de amor de y mil por el
rey y que los que merecían morir como
rainer ya ni viven felices y sin
consecuencias los que en realidad
merecían vivir como eren con la misma mi
casa tengan un final triste y
desesperanzador pero bueno estas son
cosas que puedo dejar pasar proyectos
aspectos mucho mayores que si me
molestan un poco más como por ejemplo el
hecho de que todo lo que hizo era su
sacrificio y sus ideales prácticamente
no sirvieron para una [ __ ] pues al
final aún siguen en guerra es decir si
armen y los demás ya no son una amenaza
pero la guerra aún existe es como si
todo lo que eren trató de hacer fue
arrojado a la basura y mi casa
mi casa fue el personaje al que peor
trataron en la serie miren yo entiendo
que la serie es muy oscura y triste y un
final feliz tal vez era mucho pedir para
mi casa pero no me jodan mi casa
literalmente terminó la serie llorando
mientras pasa sus días junto a la tumba
de una persona con la que jamás podrá
estar el cabrón lo que quiero decir es
que si siento que el final pudo haber
sido mil veces mejor tomarnos a su
tiempo para explicar ciertos temas y en
general dar un cierre más digno esta
gran historia pero como he dicho ya
varias veces no todo es malo pues
personalmente no lo consiguieron al
final al menos les da un cierre a las
historias de los personajes y deja la
historia algo inconclusa pero con un
final lo suficientemente aceptable como
para que podamos ver que la historia de
aquellos niños que vimos hace muchos
años ya terminó
sino que hoy en siempre fue la historia
con un tono serio y algo triste supo
mantener su esencia hasta el final y
creo que en lugar de tirarle odio a la
serie al capítulo final deberíamos estar
agradecidos con allí misa llama por
pasar 12 años de su vida esforzándose
por darnos una gran experiencia creando
personajes y una historia que siempre
recordaremos
de acuerdo ya habiendo hablado del
episodio final quiero discutir
brevemente sobre la serie como tal y que
fue la que la hizo tan especial la serie
fue estrenada en 2009 pero fue realmente
en 2013 con la llegada de su anime que
se convertiría en una de las series más
aclamadas y es que la serie llegó en una
época en donde mayormente estábamos
rodeados de historias alegres y con
seres supremamente poderosos y nos dio
historia más humana con personajes que
llegaban a entender mucho más miremos
por ejemplo a eren eres no se mantiene
como el mismo personaje a lo largo de
toda la serie a medida que los capítulos
avanzan eren crece y cambia hasta que en
el final se convierte en un villano lo
cual me pareció genial r nunca fue un
santo es un personaje más humano de lo
que nos gustaría aceptar siente tristeza
ira y odio y al final demuestra que la
guerra puede cambiar a cualquiera pero
algo de lo que más hizo destacar la
serie es su frialdad a la hora de tratar
a los personajes sino que hoy en de
manera muy similar a cannes es una de
esas series en donde se tiene que morir
un personaje morirá a pesar de tener
personajes interesantes y muy
entrañables la serie sabía que ningún
personaje tenía que crearse más de lo
que tenían que hacerlo ejemplos hay
muchos
y tuvo una gran evolución a lo largo de
la serie y siempre fue un apoyo para
todos los personajes pero cuando su
tiempo en la serie se estaba terminando
no se creó innecesariamente simplemente
murió erwin demonios erwin era uno de
los mejores personajes de toda la serie
el tipo de una máquina de emoción a eso
le bastaba con abrir su bocota para
hacer que cualquier infeliz al borde de
la muerte de su vida por la legión
felizmente erwin tu algunos de los
mejores momentos en toda la serie y
ahora sí cuando la serie avanzó de su
personaje había cumplido su rol
inevitablemente murió tal vez la única
excepción a esto es libia y quien a mi
parecer debió morir en la batalla final
contra eren pero más allá de eso la
serie siempre nos ofreció un mundo cruel
y realista en donde nadie estaba seguro
y nadie se quedaba más de lo necesario
y el anime que llegó en 2013 fue el que
elevó la popularidad de la serie
enormemente y con muchísima razón pues
el manga es bueno pero el anime el anime
es una mezcla de todo lo que alguien
podría buscar en una serie gran
animación y diseño una historia
interesante asombrosas actuaciones de
voz y música increíble tanto en opening
y ending como en la banda sonora el
anime aprovechó todos los aspectos
buenos del manga y lo resalto lo
suficiente como para que sea una obra
reconocida mundialmente la historia
siempre fue algo que esperabas ver si es
verdad que en algún momento se pasó con
la política pero a la larga es algo que
vale la pena ver pues ayudarnos a
entender la importancia de futuros
conflictos y su arco final el arco del
retumbar fue para mí de los mejores
arcos de la serie eren sucumbiendo a sus
emociones y volviéndose un villano las
dos facciones en guerra uniéndose para
derrotar a un mal mayor en general
durante el retumbar la serie recortó los
aspectos que la volvieron tan buena
cuando inicio
en general zinc equino que hoy in es una
de las mejores series que puedes
encontrar no es para nada perfecta y si
tuvo un fin algo común y algo regular
económicas toda la serie como tal es una
obra que logró darnos una gran historia
que durante 12 años nos dio grandes
emociones y logro mantenernos al
pendiente de que sucedería capítulo tras
capítulo ya sea manga o en animes indicó
que hoy en pasar a la historia como una
de las mejores series y todo gracias al
trabajo de una persona que durante 12
años dio todo de sí mismo para que
nosotros podamos disfrutar de su obra
gracias a jimmy se llama por darnos tan
increíble historia gracias por singh ex
novio jim
[Música]